oh yeah time to talk about some cool
[ __ ] so then your trailer to Iron Man
has come out on what your grandmother
calls the interwebs so we're gonna talk
about this
I'm Tony Stark I build neat stuff I got
a great girl and occasionally save the
world I love that description that's
Tony Stark pretty much being like I'm
awesome
in case you didn't know and we did know
from the other trailers that Tony Stark
is gonna be tested in this movie in ways
that he hasn't been tested before
it's chapter three of a trilogy it's
gonna happen like that the douchebag
from die hard to like all right the
Mandarin must be stopped I will defend
this country at all cost the Mandarin
must be stopped
okay all right it's not a secret in this
movie they're like the mandarins back
he's out there he's doing bad things
it's almost like he's gonna shoot
rockets at Tony Stark's house coolest
part is that salute you see that salute
America the work is is just America be
America and all the American America is
that could be America and I already knew
from the other Iron Man trailers this
movie looks like it's gonna be business
and this trailer does nothing to shake
my faith in that
I really feel like pepper pastas gonna
die in this movie she's never gonna die
she's in trouble
Mandarin kind of has a funny voice
though doesn't it you'll never see me
coming
sounds like if Nixon in the Joker had a
kid that's the Mandarin key to being an
evil villain draw out your syllables
it's the key to anyone who wants to
sound evil and it looks like I'm um the
Mandarin causing a bunch of trouble Tony
Stark's done he's like Superman in
Superman 2 he's like yeah the whole
world's gonna be watching the question
where is Tony Stark things are different
now
I have to protect the one thing I can't
live without that's you I don't know
maybe that's when he's just laying in
the snow or something point is he's not
around and maybe it will show maybe it
won't show but this is where my mind
goes is that it'll illustrate that when
you rely so much on one thing to protect
you when that thing is gone what do you
have you got Ben Kingsley who has you by
the balls cuz you'll never see him
coming
no Mickey Rourke and Iron Man 2 was like
if you can make God bleed people will
cease to believe in him that was his
whole campaign this one Ben Kingsley's
like I'll do something better I'll blow
up his big billion-dollar Malibu mansion
God's probably a little pissed now my
favorite part of this one trailer I know
the end is really epic and I'll get to
that but my favorite part is when Tony
Stark is talking and he's like I'm not
afraid of you and he's pretty much
calling him out I'm not afraid of you
gonna politics here
just good old-fashioned revenge he's
like yeah I'm a good guy I'm a badass
but in the end I'm still a human being
revenge is not off the table and of
course they gotta close off the trailer
with something that's really cool you
know Tony Stark's back up which good you
know maybe a couple of Iron Men or you
know 50 will do 50 the best part
metalheads in the movie yeah metalhead
from Ninja Turtles totally in the movie
Tony Stark created metalhead you know
meme big Iron Man fan I love the Iron
Man hero I love Tony Stark the person
this trailer comes out it shows us yeah
it's still epic as hell if the next wave
of Marvel movie sequels is leading up to
the Avengers 2 what is the Avengers 2
gonna be how epic will that be I don't
need to think that far ahead right now
as it stands Iron Man 3 looks completely
badass right so Iron Man 3 what are you
thinking about this have you seen the
trailer whatever you think whatever your
thoughts however excited you are and if
somehow you think this movie's gonna be
[ __ ] weird the possible comment
below let me know what you think and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]